Thank you very much
for saving my house.It's nice to meet
you.This place is very important
to me.
[Applause]
ran
ani
[Music] It
's no good ww Yonee daran
[Music]
Even if you look at the farm, it still has a great impact.
That's what it's like, isn't it? The guys in this second
calmly accept the naked apron, and it
's strange that it's so strange that it's a strange thing.
There are so many keys, it's normal
It's amazing to be able to handle an opportunity full of
buttons like that, is
n't it?
Yes, they're really strange people, and it's nice to be in the center of them.
And you're still Hisako,
is it me?
I have a
hunch that maybe it's that man who will save this October from thistle.
it's good